as cp 682 versus the gate guardian can  the giant warrior with a sword hotter  than the sun finally kill the  hard-to-destroy reptile when scp-682 was  brought in to hopefully meet its  ultimate destruction at the gate the  guardian guards it quipped is this meant  to be the garden  this is not the garden the garden is far  west of here when the gate guardian  struck 682 it was grievously wounded  with only a single leg left as it  regenerated it snarled at the gate  guardians saying die you command me to  die oh wouldn't we all like that but  this is my curse for suggesting the  fruit it struck again and before passing  out from its injuries 682 said  this is not the garden and you are not  uriel pretender